Lewis Jackson sat with all his fellow students
in the dingy, underground lecture hall, listening
to a rickety old professor with a voice like
chloroform rattling off dry facts about economics.
Above him, a projector older than any of the
students in the room covered the wall in a
poorly-designed PowerPoint presentation, limping
from slide to slide.
It was 9 AM on a thoroughly unremarkable Monday.
Half the class was hungover, the other was
just terminally bored.
Lewis hoped none of this would come up on
the final, because this morning, he had no
intention of listening.
Instead, he was typing out a message under
the desk with a big, stupid grin on his face.
“Professor Harbison is going off about the
free market again.
Save me.”
Send.
The message’s recipient, Jenny Park, started
typing.
Lewis’ crush on Jenny was the college’s
worst kept secret.
Ever since they met during O-Week, he’d
been infatuated with her.
They shared a few classes, but little by little,
they started hanging out more in their free
time.
Study sessions, grabbing lunch together, going
to the movies.
They’d become fast friends, but Lewis was
hoping they could be something more - and
he hoped, deep down, Jenny was thinking the
same thing.
He received a text.
“We can hang out in the quad after if it
makes him easier to endure.
We’ll grab burgers, my treat.”
With a winking emoji.
Lewis felt like a dork to admit it, even to
himself, but this message made his heart race.
They were doing winking emojis now?
Maybe today wouldn’t be such a drag after
all.
Any day that he got to hang out with Jenny
couldn’t be all bad.
All of this news was so exciting to him, he
didn’t notice that something strange was
sweeping over the lecture hall.
While the professor droned on, even the most
studious members of the class were suddenly
checking their phones, faces alight with expressions
of confusion, then concern, then worry.
Something was happening.
Something big.
Professor Harbison fell silent as a new sound
rose to prominence - Muffled at first but
getting rapidly louder, just outside the lecture
hall.
It was screaming.
Terrible screams of fear and pain.
People started to rise out of their seats.
What was going on out there?
Nobody had heard gunshots or an explosion.
The ground wasn’t rumbling under their feet,
and if a hurricane or a tornado was tearing
its way across the campus, they would have
heard it.
Suddenly, the main doors to the lecture hall
burst open, and a terrified student rushed
through.
Lewis recognized him: It was Tommy Lansdale,
a History Major that Lewis had hung out with
a few times at campus parties.
He was a chill guy, the kind of person who
took everything on the chin and let life’s
troubles just roll off his back.
That’s why it was so strange to see his
whole body shaking, and his face a red mess
of tears.
“You can’t go out there!” he screamed.
“There’s something wrong with the light.”
Concern was starting to give way to panic.
Tommy turned and shoved the bolt into place
on the door, eliminating the potential exit.
The only other way out was a fire escape down
by the stage.
His heavy breathing and choked sobs weren’t
doing much to calm anyone down.
Lewis checked his phone again.
Jenny was still typing.
Tommy kept repeating, “Something wrong with
the light, something wrong with the light,
something wrong with the light...”
The other students were starting to approach
him, all with a sense of guarded caution,
given they still didn’t understand the situation
well enough to know for sure that Tommy wasn’t
the dangerous one here.
College could be an extremely stressful place;
it definitely wasn’t unheard of for people
to snap under the pressure and do something
they wouldn’t normally do.
“What’s going on, man?”
Lewis said, walking briskly up to Tommy, worried
about Jenny’s safety if something really
was happening out there.
Tommy raised both hands in a gesture that
seemed halfway between pleading and a threat,
shaking his head frantically.
“Stay back, dude, you don’t wanna go out
there, something terrible is happening!”
Professor Harbison approached, adjusting his
glasses and sneering.
He didn’t take kindly to someone interrupting
his lecture with these ridiculous theatrics.
An institute of learning was no place for
this kind of troublemaker.
“I demand you leave this instant, young
man,” Harbison said.
“If you don’t stop this foolish behavior,
I’ll have you written up.”
Tommy didn’t budge.
He just shook his head emphatically.
“I’m not going anywhere,” he said.
“If you go out there, you’re gonna die.
I’m not letting anyone leave this damn building!”
Before anyone could protest this unwilling
confinement, a terrible sound started to come
from outside.
Not screaming this time, just a voice.
A warped, pained voice that seemed almost
to droop as it spoke, like a voice recorded
on an old reel-to-reel tape recorder that’s
starting to degrade.
“Help me,” it slurred.
“Please, let me in, I feel so sick...”
There was a terrible slopping noise, like
a thick, viscous liquid sluicing closer.
Tommy looked down and screamed.
Flesh-colored slime was slithering in underneath
the door and dripping over the top step of
the gangway.
Tommy stepped back, along with everyone else.
It looked revolting and smelled even worse
- like a mixture of rotten meat and burning
hair.
That terrible drooping voice was still somehow
emanating from the slime.
“Please... Please help me...
Something went wrong...”
Naturally, the other students began to scream
and run.
Whatever that monster was, they needed to
get away from it, quickly.
Only Lewis seemed to be rooted in place, the
terror and impossibility of it all just paralyzing
him.
He could only watch as the flesh-colored blob
creature seeped in under the door.
Everyone else, including Professor Harbison
- who was moving faster than he had in years
- made a mad dash for the fire exit down by
the stage.
Tommy screamed for them to stay inside, but
it was already too late.
People panicked and piled on top of each other
to get out, but the second they did, the worst
of the screaming started.
The most awful, agonized wails you’ve ever
heard, that tapered off in that same drooping
gurgle as the blob slithering in underneath
the door.
It was Lewis’ natural instinct to run down
and help, somehow, but instead, he felt Tommy’s
white-knuckle grip on his shoulder.
“I’m sorry,” Tommy said through sobs.
“It’s too late for them.
There’s nothing you can do.
We just need to stay inside.”
At that moment, Lewis received a text message
from Jenny, it read:
“Lewis, if you’re still okay, you need
to read this and you need to believe me.
Something terrible has happened.
So many people are dead.
Or at least, I think they’re dead, a lot
of them are still screaming.
I think it has something to do with the sun.
Stay out of the light.
I’m in Administration Building C. I’m
safe, for now, but I’m hiding.
Don’t come looking for me until nightfall.
Please let me know if you’re okay.
You can’t trust the sun.”
Lewis felt a wave of relief and terror wash
over him: Jenny was okay, and that was great
news.
But it seemed like this nightmare, whatever
the hell it was, was affecting everyone out
there.
It was a force melting people down and turning
them into monsters.
The screams from outside the door were getting
worse.
All those people who had been, well, people
so recently were something entirely different
now.
And they were in terrible, terrible pain.
Lewis and Tommy ran down to the fire escape
next to the stage and forced it shut, trying
not to look at the tide of liquid flesh that
was roiling in the apparently hostile sun
outside.
They were lost now; Tommy and Lewis didn’t
want them coming back in.
Lewis breathed a rattling sigh and hammered
out a reply to Jenny.
“I’m safe in a lecture hall with Tommy
Lansdale.
We’ll come to you as soon as we can.
Don’t worry, it’s all going to be okay.”
Lewis shoved his phone back into his pocket.
Now isn’t the time to keep checking.
He asked Tommy what he knew.
How had he survived…
Whatever all this was?
Having some kind of knowledge about what they
were dealing with might have given them a
better chance of surviving.
Tommy had just finished up a seminar in a
nearby classroom and was heading over to the
canteen to grab a Reuben while preparing for
his next class.
He was lucky enough to be under a covered
walkway, bathed in the early morning shade,
when something about the sun changed.
It was hard to even describe - A certain shift
in the quality of the light, a kind of shimmer,
almost.
It didn’t affect him, but the people in
the courtyard a few feet away…
He was shuddering as he told the next part
of the story.
He swallowed hard over a lump in his throat,
staring off into the distance with a haunted
look as the memories played over his mind.
Tommy described the people in the courtyard,
the ones out of the shade who were first exposed…
They just started screaming and falling apart.
Losing form.
Melting.
Becoming awful piles of shapeless slop on
the ground.
It was instantaneous, and all it seemed to
take was a fraction of a second of sun exposure
for the whole process to take effect.
Nothing was worth the risk of exposure to
something like that.
Nothing.
But Lewis disagreed.
There was one thing worth risking his life
or the integrity of his body for: Jenny.
They had to get to Administration Building
C as quickly as possible.
And not just because of the new threat raging
outside, but because Building C already had
a certain…
Reputation.
Rumor had it that a number of people had gone
missing in that building back in the 1970s.
Since then, people had experienced strange,
inexplicable things.
Odd chills.
Strange noises.
Creeping feelings of doom in certain areas.
In short, it was the last place Lewis wanted
Jenny to be trapped.
But neither he nor Tommy could help until
night fell, seeing as they wouldn’t be great
rescuers in a semi-liquid state.
They waited for ten torturous hours in that
lecture hall as day turned to night outside.
In that time, they heard so many terrible
bubbling screams out there - Pain trying to
escape a slimy prison.
It was enough to drive you mad with fear.
Both checked the news and their Twitter feeds
on their phones, hoping to find out if there
was any more information on what was happening
out there.
It seemed the worst had come to pass: This
insane phenomenon was unfolding everywhere.
People across the world were suffering under
the transforming rays of the terrible new
sun.
Some group called the “SCP Foundation”
was releasing information about it, telling
people to come towards their buildings at
night for safety.
Lewis committed this fact to memory.
When they’d collected Jenny, they’d head
straight to one of these buildings.
Hopefully someone there could tell them what
the hell was going on here.
Someone out there had to have answers about
all this.
When it got dark outside, Lewis felt his phone
buzz in his pocket as he received another
text from Jenny.
This time, it was:
“Lewis I’m scared.
Please come quickly.
I’m downstairs.”
And with that, Lewis knew it was time to leave.
He and Tommy steeled themselves, and when
they were sure it was dark out, they ventured
forth from the lecture hall and onto the quad.
There, they saw the aftermath of the horrors
that the sun had wrought.
The grass was covered in more huge, flesh-colored
blobs, slithering across the grass like mutant
slugs.
Just the sight of them made Lewis and Tommy
feel nauseous, but they didn’t have time
to stop and take a breather.
If Jenny was in trouble, they needed to get
to Building C, fast.
It looked even more frightening at night.
It occurred to both Lewis and Tommy at that
moment that neither of them had ever actually
been inside this building before, and what
seemed like the end of the world was certainly
an interesting time to start.
Lewis and Tommy entered the building and turned
on the lights in the lobby.
They heard a voice at first, oddly toneless
and robotic, but soon realized it was a video
playing on loop on the computer at the unmanned
reception desk.
It was another message from the SCP Foundation.
“This is a Public Service Announcement from
the SCP Foundation.
We are commandeering all broadcast channels
and frequencies to deliver a vital message.
Avoid sunlight at all costs.
Cover your bodies thoroughly.
And follow the instructions on the screen
to reach the nearest operational SCP Foundation
containment site…”
Neither liked the sound of the phrase “Containment
Site”, but they’d worry about the semantics
later.
Jenny had said she’d been hiding “downstairs”,
and there was no sign of her here on the first
floor, so it stood to reason she was on some
kind of basement level.
Strange.
It seemed like all the doors here led up…
Except one.
A door that looked like, until very recently,
it had been bolted to the wall.
“Well…” Lewis said, trying to mask his
fear.
“I guess it’s now or never.”
Tommy opened his mouth to answer, but before
a single word could pass his lips, a huge,
fleshy tendril shot through the front door
of the building and wrapped around his throat.
He managed only a choked gasp as it dragged
him back towards the door.
On the other side of the threshold, a mountain
of flesh eagerly waited.
A gibbering nightmare of half-formed faces
screamed and wailed in the terrible fleshy
form.
It happened so quickly that Lewis couldn’t
even hope to save him.
He was gone, subsumed by the blob, his face
disappearing into the flesh before Lewis could
even scream.
But there was no time to stop and process
the shock.
Another several tendrils were already reaching
for him; he could practically see it happening
in slow motion.
Pulsing.
Grasping for him.
Perhaps it was only his will to see Jenny
again that gave him the strength to do so,
but he dodged the tendrils by a fraction of
an inch and dove towards the door - the same
door he assumed Jenny had escaped into hours
earlier.
He threw open the door and disappeared behind
it, slamming it in place and holding it fast.
He could feel the tendrils smashing up against
it, hammering away.
Lewis heard all those terrible, deranged voices
screaming for him on the other side.
He was holding it for ten solid minutes before
the creature finally gave up and slithered
away.
The second the silence fell, Lewis’ phone
buzzed in his pocket again.
He fished it out and saw another message from
Jenny.
It read:
“Please come.
Afraid.
So dark here, so dark here, so dark here,
so dark here, so dark here…”
And it was at that moment that Lewis began
to take in his new surroundings.
He was standing in a stairwell, one that seemed
much older and more dilapidated than even
the rest of the building.
But most notable of all was the fact that
he had never, ever seen a place so dark.
Impossibly dark.
Not “dark” as in the absence of light,
but dark as an almost physical presence, choking
out the light.
Even with his phone on full power, the light
didn’t penetrate much of the black.
Was Jenny all the way down here?
Lewis was afraid, but he could only imagine
how Jenny was feeling down there in the depths.
He took a deep breath and started descending
down into the darkness, using his phone camera
to light what little of the way was possible.
The deeper he got, the more he started to
feel a strange, intangible dread beginning
to creep in, like an invisible hand compressing
his chest.
As he got deeper, he noticed a sound: Quiet
weeping.
An unmistakably female voice, somewhere down
below.
It sounded too young to be Jenny, but then
again, Lewis had never actually heard her
cry before.
Whatever the case, he needed to get down there
and remedy the situation.
He forged on, further and further into the
dark, even as his terrible sense of dread
increased.
He couldn’t help but notice that no matter
how far down he went, it always sounded like
the crying was the same distance away.
It unnerved him, but Jenny had to be down
there.
She had to be.
And even if he gave up on her, it’s not
like he could just go back up and leave.
There were monsters out there - like the monster
that’d gotten Tommy.
Even down here in the darkness, he was safer
than up there.
Or at least, that’s what he thought.
He felt something strange under his foot and
looked down.
It was an old piece of torn-up orange fabric,
with “D-9884” written on it.
The phone buzzed again.
A new message from Jenny.
This time it read, “I can see you.
Can you see me?”
Lewis looked around.
He couldn’t see anything.
He tried desperately calling Jenny again.
He yelled her name until his voice went hoarse.
No reply.
Just that same soft weeping so far below.
Maybe she was on the flight below him.
She must have been close.
He doubled his speed, vaulting down the stairs
to the next level, when he noticed something
on the ground.
A Smart Phone - One that, over so many study
dates, lunches, and outings to the movies,
he’d learned to recognize.
It was Jenny’s.
He picked it up, studying it, only to see
that it was dead, the screen cracked and the
battery lifeless.
His own phone gave another buzz.
A text from Jenny.
It read, “Look down.”
And, against all rational thought, that’s
exactly what he did.
There was something at the bottom of the stairs.
A strange, pale face, somehow illuminated
in the darkness.
At first, he thought it could have been her,
and ran towards it.
By the time he realized he was wrong, and
he was staring into the blank eyes of a face
without a mouth, inches from his own face,
it was already too late.
Lewis let out a scream, but there was nobody
there to hear him.
But on the bright side, at least he never
would see that sunlight again…
Now go check out “The Secret at the Bottom
of SCP-087 - EXPLAINED” and “SCP-087 Trapped
in the Stairwell” for more tales of the
terrible things that happen when you enter
a certain anomalous stairwell…